so I'm Jim kitchen uh sorry for my voice
I'm a little under the weather right now
but I work at Anaconda
um Eric is over at Nvidia and we've
worked together in the past
um
and the third presenter in riddle Seth
um he's one of the core developers at
Network X
um his internet's a little spotty today
so I'll just be presenting for him
instead
um but we want to talk about making
Network X faster uh specifically 100 or
more times faster uh with a feature
called dispatching to graph plus and
we'll get into that in a bit
um so first of all just to sort of set
the minimum Foundation of why graphs are
important
um
first of all if you know I assume
everyone knows about social networks
like Facebook and Twitter where each
person is a node in the graph and the
connections between them are like
Facebook friends or Twitter followers
other other you know social connections
um graphs can also be used for route
planning where intersections are the
nodes and then the actual roads form the
connections
um and sometimes roads you know only go
one way or have a speed limit but with
those you can use graph algorithms to do
route planning for instance and make
Google Maps work
um sometimes in higher end tables you
have hierarchical relationships we have
a many to one like who is my employer
and what you find is while you know SQL
and others can handle things like that
It's Tricky when you don't know how many
levels deep you need to go
um question like how many employees are
in jeannette's organization you don't
know how many times you need to join the
table to itself to answer that so
framing that as a graph problem is
usually the right way to go so that's
just basic of why graphs are important
and why people care about them today
we're specifically talking about Network
X which is an amazing Library uh it's
it's the most popular graph and network
library in Python
and you know if I had to pick a
superhero for Network X I'd pick
Spider-Man
he shoots webs uh it feels appropriate
and of course Spider-Man is amazing and
so is Network X and let me talk about
the the ways that Network X is amazing
first of all it's amazingly easy to use
uh it's a pure python package it has
easily understandable object model so
just dictionary of dictionaries a nice
stable API
it's amazingly well documented if you go
to networkx.org it's got tutorials
introductory materials you know a
gallery educational notebooks all kind
of good stuff
it's amazingly easy to contribute to so
it's got a developer guide a very
friendly community and the source code
is very readable so it's easy for you
know someone who's more on the academic
side to come in and start contributing
it's amazingly flexible anything that is
hashable can be used as a node in the
graph you can add multiple properties to
nodes or edges you know some might say
it's a little too flexible but for now
this is a good power
and of course it's amazingly slow for
large graphs this is this is why the
talk comes
um you know this is known for a long
time anytime you're iterating with
python for Loops over dictionary of
dictionaries it's going to be slow so
the question is is there a way we could
solve that last problem to keep Network
X amazing
so what are potential solutions to this
one is just to wait for Hardware to get
faster you know Moore's law has saved us
in the past but the problem is that data
is growing larger at a faster rate than
processors are getting faster so this
really is not a solution
um another thing you could do is just
try to rewrite everything right throw it
all away start
um you know go down to a bat cave hire
Lucius Fox is a genius and write some I
don't know C plus a rust craft library
and and these have been done
um the problem with this approach though
is that you basically lose the community
you lose all those other amazing aspects
of network X so we don't really want to
go this route
instead our proposal is a thing called
dispatching which I think you know
easily most easily explained is
um you know Spider-Man is is great
around New York City um you know he can
sling his webs and and swing between
buildings he's great
um but as soon as your graphs grow to
the size of like the United States
um having Spider-Man just running
through Kansas is really slow he needs
to instead catch right on a bullet train
or something
and so this is our approach is having
um users still interact with with
Spider-Man right with network X
um but add extra capabilities where
Spider-Man can now catch rides on faster
libraries on bullet trains if you will
all right so the vision here is Network
X both as a reference implementation and
also as an API
so if we if we step back and just look
at python has its own superpowers
um you know why is it why is it the
number one thing for machine learning
and Ai and other things it's because it
has a very nice API that users like
interacting with but Library authors go
a lot deeper they go into compiled
libraries they add bindings and expose
the API but the the users of those
libraries don't ever have to dig into
that right you can use tensorflow
without knowing C plus
and that's a superpower
if we look at one of the biggest success
stories in Python numpy
um you know numpy wraps a lot of C code
Fortran it has cython and other things
but when you just install numpy and use
it you don't have to care about that it
just works
and so numpy is a very nice interface
um it has exposed an array interface to
actually let other objects masquerade as
as numpy objects and in fact other array
libraries like dasc.array and coupon
wrap their own set of different things
and have sort of mimicked the numpy API
so while numpy is both an implementation
it also has sort of become this API
and the question is can we do the same
with network X right Network X is both a
reference implementation that that's
just fine for small graphs
um but it's also then a an API right
we've got this API layer here that you
call into but when you call into it it
could dispatch to the normal Network X
but could it dispatch to other things
right
um sci-fi sparse
um graph Bloss crew graph and the
interesting thing is if you look at
Network X today
this is what's already happening like
Network X internally is already doing
some dispatching for for example
pagerank
um the pure Network X version is too
slow so when you call pagerank with
network X it will take your network X
graph translate it to a Sci-Fi sparse
adjacency Matrix and then call the
version using scipy and it's it's faster
to do that to pay that translation cost
and run the scipy than it is to run the
network X so this is already happening a
little bit
um we just want to expand that with the
plug-in architecture and let other
libraries plug into Network X
so let's look at this in a practical
sense
um you know a dispatching example with
graph plus algorithms so first of all
this is what the network X looks like
the import Network X we're going to make
a random graph with 8000 nodes about 640
000 edges and we're going to run the
k-trust
algorithm on it in this case the the
five Truss
and on my laptop this takes about you
know look almost 11 seconds
okay if we make two small changes so we
import graph plus algorithms and then we
make a new object G2 where we just say
hey I want to make a graph plus
algorithm graph from the network X so
that it does the translation
and then the interesting thing is we
pass that G2 object directly to the K
truss of the network X
and the translation takes half a second
but running the graph plus version of
ktrust takes a quarter of a second
so you know if we ignore the translation
cost that's a 40x speed up if you
include the translation cost that's
still more than a 10x speed up
um for a graph that's honestly not that
big one thing to note is that this this
dispatching is purely opt-in right we
had to specifically pass G2 into the
um the network X ktrs algorithm now you
might be wondering how does this magic
happen so let's look behind the curtain
um this might be a little small on your
screen I apologize for that but here
this is the network x k truss algorithm
and in the 3.0 code base of network X
there's a new NX dot underscore dispatch
decorator that some of the algorithms
have been decorated with
um what happens is when you call this it
first looks at that g parameter and says
do you have a Dunder Network X plugin
attribute in our case where we passed in
G2 yes it does and it would respond
graph loss
so then it'll go and use the python
entry points mechanism
to Dig Down find the graph plus
interface it'll load that up and then
call its k-trust implementation
and you know if you aren't familiar with
entry points this is a mechanism within
python that lets you register at the
environment level so that you can query
different packages of metadata without
actually importing the data and only
once you find the right thing that you
want you call Dot load
and here that this is uh graph plus
algorithm setup.pi where we've
registered the Sentry point and so when
we called that load here it actually
goes and grabs and imports this library
in this specific class returns it here
as GB interface and then we can we can
interact with it
um so one thing to note is that not all
of the network X algorithms are
decorated at this point this is still a
little experimental of a feature
um if you want to find out you can you
you know use that to see which algorithm
decorated hopefully we'll have a better
mechanism in the future it's kind of
ugly for now
all right but if we keep looking um this
plug-in interface class you know what
what does it have to do if you were a
library author what would you have to
provide
um really there's three things you need
first of all is you need a way to you
have to have a function
with matching signature for each of the
decorated Network X algorithms that that
um that your plugin is going to support
So in our case we have this dispatcher
class and the actual implementations can
live somewhere else we just have this
place as sort of a namespace where we
pull them all in
and that way you can call NX dot any of
these and it'll you know go to our
specific implementation
there's two other pieces you need a
convert from an X and A convert to an X
method
and what these are doing is that we
added a feature where we wanted our
plugins to be able to verify that
they're working correctly they have uh
you know feature parity and you know
both in signature and in Behavior with
the original Network X implementation so
what you could do is you could actually
run the network X test here
but as long as you um export an
environment variable Network X graph
convert
um you know in our case we set equal to
graph plus if you set that right before
you run your network X by test
it will run all the network X tests but
every decorated function it will go and
take the original Network X object it'll
run it through your conversion function
so that now it's your backend graph
object
it'll then you know call things it'll do
the dispatch mechanism and then convert
your answer back into it so it can
actually compare against the original
Network X tests so with this mechanism
it lets us use graph loss algorithms we
we can run that against all of the
network X tests and therefore we know
that that we have feature parity with
network X
all right
um that's a lot already
um I'm Gonna Keep diving in just a very
brief overview of graph plus itself so
graph plus is uh solving graph
algorithms in the language of lit of
sparse linear algebra
so there is both the math spec that
explains how you take sparse linear
algebra it can actually do graph
problems
um there is a a library called sweet
Sportscraft plus this was written by Tim
Davis probably the world's foremost
expert on sparse linear algebra it's
written in C and openmp very performant
implementation we had nothing to do with
that instead we wrapped it with uh a
library called python Suite sparse graph
Bloss which takes care of all the cffi
and cython bindings and that stuff
then we added a python graph plus
Library that's pure Python and this is
sort of where we want users to interact
um but to make it really useful we
needed another layer on top graph plus
algorithms which you know writes code
using python graph plus but implements
the algorithms from Network X and other
things
so a couple features about graph Bloss
missing values are not necessarily equal
to zero that's maybe a little different
from other Sparks linear algebra
libraries
there's a concept of uh called
semi-rings where normally when you're
doing Matrix multiply in the dot product
you'd find intersecting elements you
multiply them together and then you
reduce using summation
so that's what we call the standard plus
time summary because you're you know
adding here and multiplying but you can
do other semi-rings so when you're doing
a DOT product instead you take
intersecting elements and you add them
together and then when you reduce them
you find the minimum and that's called
the Min plus semi ring why is that
useful
it turns out if you do a bunch of Matrix
multiplications you can actually solve
the like shortest path algorithms using
the Min plus some earrings so by just
adding an extra feature
um the rest of linear algebra lets you
solve graph problems it's really cool
uh there's masking involved a lot of
times in graph problems you have a
frontier that you're walking so you only
care about some of your nodes and so you
can actually pass that Frontier in as a
mask and instead of computing everything
it'll just compute you know the two or
three elements that you're interested in
and save a lot of time there
graph plus has lots of uh internal
formats so the normal CSR CSC but
there's also doubly compressed and
masked tense I already talked about how
this is you know highly tuned but it's
it's multi-core with openmp very
performant it also has connectors to
numpyte arrays so if you want to extract
out the pieces of your CSR Matrix you
can do that which lets you translate to
other sparse linear libraries and
eventually uh this graph plus is going
to support gpus
okay with that um I will turn it over to
Eric Welch
um who has been doing some fantastic
benchmarks to show what kind of
performance benefits we can get out of
craft Plus
yeah
uh thank you I forgot the privilege of
talking about benchmarks comparing graph
glass and network X and the numbers
shown here are like the speed up you get
with a graph blast in other words like
the uh how many times slower Network X
is and we build this talk it's kind of a
a hundred times faster uh version of
network X I think this is a uh safe
claim most of these are hundreds of
times faster if not thousands of times
faster
uh so we have the algorithms on the left
the data sets and their sizes on the top
and but I can like the the pain
threshold on the right which is like the
typical Network X run times of the uh
the larger graphs that we uh uh have
here which are mostly on the right side
so if you have a large graph of network
X you'll typically start by just asking
the simplest thing
or like the uh get the degree centrality
compute degrees and indeed like this is
not that painful it still takes just
about a second it's virtually instant in
graph loss
but as we increase the complexity even
just uh slightly like let's get the
reciprocity which asks the questions of
how many people do I follow follow me
back
and this takes a matter of minutes in
network X whereas it's like 2 000 times
faster in crap loss which is still
instant if we increase the complexity a
little bit more like okay let's look at
the degrees of all of my neighbors
or like how popular are my friends uh
this takes tens of minutes like it's
still not that part of a query and let
me get even
uh address
um adds a bit more complexity and now
we're talking about hours
so as you do a grasp with these you know
not really that large graphs uh your
pain threshold quickly
um
like your pain quickly increases uh the
next group of uh benchmarks want to do
power iterations
and hey drink
um is the only one of these that what
we're nowhere connects first converts it
to sci-fi sparse
and then computes the page rank with the
same price first and this conversion is
worth it like we get it done in about a
minute
uh but that conversion is not free
and sci-fi sparse is still slower than
graph glass
um and so uh
graph losses thousands of times faster
typically and as we move down the table
like eigenvector centrality uh it starts
taking hours uh cat centrality uh takes
hours to days
um so I I call that very painful
and like where it gets more painful like
graph lives actually tends to do better
because it's multi-threaded I think the
last group is interesting because we are
Computing triangles and squares like if
how many um like nodes are connected by
edges that make the triangle you might
wonder oh how do we compute triangles or
squares using like Matrix multiply
Primitives and the answer is cleverly
and uh quickly
uh so these are like thousands of times
and sometimes like 10 000 or 20 times
faster
the network X which starts to get pretty
painful uh Square clustering uh the ones
that didn't finish yet uh now it's still
running like these are days into the
benchmarks I'm curious how long it will
actually take
um the most painful thing here is the
square clustering that hasn't finished
yet like
like uh in graph blasts most of these
take a matter of like seconds or at
worst tens of seconds
um
but maybe it's not fair to compare
against Network X because hey that's
pure python uh so let's compare against
uh a Sci-Fi implementation of hey drink
where it does the same exact computation
uh just using sci-fi sparse arrays and
it's doing that sci-fi can express well
for the large graphs on the right you
see a graph class because it's
multi-threaded
um it can still be like 20 times faster
uh which is significant
um but for these data sets sci-fi still
only takes you know about a second
um and as Jim noted with his example
earlier like these data sets really
aren't that large for graph loss it's
like 30 million edges uh we can easily
do like 100 times larger
on a workstation and basically it's
limited by memory so if you have a a
beefy workstation you can go a thousand
times a larger
next slide
which brings us to a coup graphic if you
want uh superpowers go no further than
Rapids AI uh started by Nvidia
um
Rapids is a collection of
um interoperable libraries like qdf is
like pandas kuml is like cycle learn
true graph is like Network X
and here
um I'm showing two benchmarks where we
run page rank on a 1.1 trillion Edge
graph
uh on 2000 gpus in the completes in less
than 20 seconds
and louvain on a 1.1 trillion Edge graph
on a thousand gpus computes in about
five and a half minutes
which is just incredible uh so kugref
um since it's like Network X is a
natural uh
library to have as a plugin to network X
and we're excited to do that
um a bit more about graphic it does work
well on a single GPU
and multiple gpus and it's targeting gnm
workflows
uh so the crew graph team is very
exciting
um just to make dispatching better for
everybody and to have it dispatch you
know to the GPU uh
talk to you Jim okay thank you Eric
all right with that um we're gonna talk
about a little bit about the future of
dispatching
um so just a quick reminder that uh you
know
right now well in network X 3.0 which is
still not Mainline um but it should be
in a couple days hopefully
um dispatching is is currently opt-in
um but if we look at the future of what
what this could be
um we want to talk about automatic
dispatching
um this is similar to what uh network is
already doing with the scipy
implementation for pagerank
um where it takes your network X graph
it automatically converts it to the back
end implementation or you know the graph
fit uh graph type calls that algorithm
and then converts back
um you know this would be this would
require basically zero changes to your
code you would instead just install a
plug-in in your environment and things
would get faster
um this would obviously require you know
estimates about the conversion time and
and the algorithm runtime for that
plug-in
and deciding what happens if I have
multiple plugins right if I have kugraph
and graph plus algorithms installed
which one has a priority order
um memoizing converted graphs today if
you were to call you know pagerank with
two different convergence criterias but
the same graph it would have to convert
that graph twice
um you know it seems like caching that
conversion makes sense but obviously
caching needs to be done thoughtfully so
you don't run out of memory
lazy eye operations uh normally most
graphs that you're going to use you load
from disk either a CSV or some Matrix
Market format or you know pulled from a
database and so if you load that into a
network X graph first and then are going
to translate it to some other format can
we skip the network X immediately if we
lazy load and just have that as a
delayed task and then decide all right
I'm going to run this against kugraft
does kugraph have a way to read that
that CSV file directly for instance or
does graph loss algorithms so more more
ways to again get better improvements
but of course anytime we're doing this
kind of magic stuff uh if something goes
wrong the user really needs to know what
path did
you know did Network X take did it use
the the normal implementation or what
are these plugins so we we'd need really
good debugging logging
um introspection all those kind of
things
um so again this is this is all future
work
um not started but something that we
want to do and would love help with
so some key takeaways from from this
first of all Network X is amazing uh yes
it may be slow but it's still an amazing
library with an amazing Community
um and we think it it has a long way to
go we just want to speed it up
um dispatching can make it you know 100x
or more faster uh really we want
Spider-Man just to you know catch right
on that bullet train
and and you know have lots of different
options Planes Trains whatever
um that a reminder though that you know
the user still interacts with network X
right they just make a call to their
friendly neighborhood Spiderman
Spiderman's the one that knows all the
train schedules and all that stuff you
don't have to deal with that
um it's still nice and easy Spiderman
just goes faster
um of course I work on graph blast so I
got to put a plug-in that you know if
graph law sounded interesting
um it's really elegant a way to do graph
problems come check it out come join our
community it's it's still a growing area
and lastly I really hope the network X
can become the graph API for python just
like uh you know python is is the
standard way of doing machine learning I
would love for python to be what people
reach for when they have a graph problem
rather than you know some other Library
so a couple calls to action at the end
of this talk
um first of all if you're a network X
User you know give it a try uh Network X
3.0 will be releasing soon
um you know don't be afraid to reach for
graph plus algorithms or kugraph or any
other plugin that comes out in the
future give it a try and enjoy the
faster speed
if you are a graph Library contributor
maybe in the past you sort of have
looked down on network X you say hey
I've got this awesome graph Library it
it runs circles around Network X that's
fine that's fine uh but Network Xiao
he's Spider-Man's over here trying to
give you a high five uh you know reach
out give him a high five back join the
team
um together we can we can make
everything better
um Network X will you know ship work off
to you and make more people aware of
your library
um use it and similarly you can benefit
the whole Community as a community of
python uh we can we can make graphs more
awesome
and lastly we would love feedback from
everyone you know dispatching is a very
early concept I've I've sort of
mentioned some things I would like to
see in dispatching 2.0 but really
there's a whole Multiverse of
possibilities and you know if you guys
try it out and give feedback you can
shape what it becomes
um so yeah give it a try
and if you do want to try it out
um again this is in network X 3.0
Unfortunately today it's not yet
Mainline so if you want to install it
you have to do pip install Network x
dash dash pre and that will get you the
the version that actually works
um install graph plus and some optional
dependency there's there's the command
to install graph plus and do the
conversion from Network exit at least
needs scipy you probably want pandas in
there for a nice display
um and then here is the GitHub site uh
with a little dispatch example to kind
of
dip your feet in so with that
um I will end and ask if anyone has
questions
what perfect timing
oh it's just popping on
um it does not look like we have any
questions coming in yet but we'll give
people a couple
um minutes if anybody
um that is watching has any questions
please drop those in the comments
um and Jim and Eric I know would be very
happy to answer anything you have
yep we're happy to talk about you know
Network X dispatching or just graph loss
or crew graph
um any of that stuff
and if nobody does have any questions we
can
um Jim and Eric can continue the
conversation in Discord
um you all can drop your presentation in
Discord as well if you want to provide
your slides for folks that might want to
go back and reference or we'll be
watching this at a later time
okay
and I don't see any
um comments coming in oh here's one
can you see that there on the screen
well on M1 yes so I should note um the
the conda packages should work on every
platform they should work on Windows uh
Mac M1 the PIP packages
um we need to do a little bit of work
um for graph loss uh it it's having
issues on Windows and Mac arm
so but but if you do install with conda